in this video I'll be analyzing how
horror in 2018 stacks up with other
years for the genre if you want to hear
what might be in store for 2019 then
stick around to the end of this video an
article has been making the rounds in
the horror community titled wasn't this
supposed to be the Golden Age of horror
the author's thesis is that the horror
genre has really deflated since last
year and there hasn't been a good scary
movie in 2018 now last time I talked
about an article on dead talks I
basically destroyed the guy to the point
that he went completely silent on the
matter and deleted all of his tweets
linking to the article my goal this time
is not to destroy anyone but to simply
look back and see how the seer stacks up
to previous years in terms of what
audiences thought what critics thought
and what I thought at least that was my
initial goal to offer an objective
comparison of each year my hypothesis
was that 2018 isn't really a bad year
overall but compared to the amazing
years we had in 2016 and to some extent
last year in 2017 2018 just doesn't have
the firepower to compete however as I
started to crunch the numbers I realized
more and more issues with this
comparison so my new point of this video
is that you can't really objectively
compare a year to year I can give my own
feelings on which years were the best
but even those are going to be skewed
and here's why the first year I started
logging every film I watched was 2014 so
let's start there this is where I first
realized the issue with this experiment
how do you define a horror film if you
include dark thrillers like dawn girl or
Nightcrawler and I'd consider 2014 to be
a pretty decent year if you take those
out you've got it follows and the guests
both of which I love but then after that
there aren't really a lot of heavy
hitters even if you only go buy horror
movies by the strictest definition of
the word they're basically countless
amounts of movies that come out every
year do you include all MPAA major
releases but then what about indie films
you try to include good bad and mid-tier
films from each year and take the
audience average critic score z' and
personal scores of each movie what
happens if you have a bunch of good
films but also a bunch of bad ones is
that considered a good year or a baddie
what if you have the best film of the
decade one year but it's weighed down by
some stinkers that also came out that
year
how do you even decide what year a movie
came out many films premiere at a
festival and then have their wide
release a different year so the year
that the majority of people watch the
movie is not the year that the movie
came out let's not even start to bring
up the fact that this article claims
2018 was a bad year for horror yet it
only talks about movies with the
addition of a couple of TV shows and
high budget webseries for simplicity's
sake we can't even get into games or
books and I know you're not gonna diss
on horror youtubers otherwise we're
gonna have a problem
but yeah I don't really see a fair way
to compare all of these years you could
frame any of them to be the worst year
of the bunch
maybe with the exception of 2016 I don't
see how anyone could come to the
conclusion that that year sucked but
then again I'm just basing that off my
opinion of the movies that I saw I try
to see movies that I think I'm going to
like but I imagine a different person
with different tastes could see a
different set of movies and have
different opinions of each movie see
this is why I analyze films and things
you missed and I'm not a rancor or a
reviewer but with that all being said
let's get to what you're here for
my opinion so we start with 2014 I'll be
going by the movie release dates listed
on a film database called tmdb it uses
the original premiere dates of the film
as a release date so although I didn't
actually get to see it follows until
2015 when it was released commercially
in theaters it will technically be
considered a 2014 film for the purposes
of this argument I can already tell you
that it follows was my favorite film of
the decade and really my favorite film
in a long time the other highlights are
as I mentioned probably closer to the
thriller side of the Venn diagram gone
girl and Nightcrawler before horror
films like the guest and Rec four and
let's get this out of the way now the
babadook I know that people love that
movie and that's fine and I found it to
be just kind of an average cliche
supernatural movie that came out
basically at the end of the supernatural
trend that Paranormal Activity started
in 2007 the following year was 2015 and
that's also pretty solid headlined by
joel edgerton surprise hits
the gift this is where we also have to
address the question of what we do with
horror-comedy since the visit is equal
parts horror and comedy I'm willing to
put that on the list insidious chapter 3
it was almost a skip for me but I'm so
glad I ended up saying it because it
might just be as good as the first
insidious I'd say 15 has a few drawbacks
though unfriended was at least funny and
unintentional lame but you may have
forgotten about it poltergeist remake
and the even more maligned Paranormal
Activity the ghost dimension I liked
both of these years but even the
strength of their highlights isn't gonna
stack up to what would fall out of my
top seven films in 2016 six of them are
in the territory of horror or dark
thriller if you saw my last video you
already know how I feel about Swift but
add on 10 Cloverfield Lane don't breathe
that lights out the arguably more
thriller oriented nerve but also the
more traditional horror piece of the boy
and you've got a stellar list of
highlights but even 2016 isn't without a
few disappointments and they came from
respectable directors like Adam wing
guards Blair Witch Rob Zombie's 31 and
gore Verbinski's returned to horror with
the cure true wellness the author of the
article seemed to have a lot of praise
for 2017 so let's take a look at what we
got that year it comes at night was the
leader of the pack for me I'll never
understand why people thought the
trailer was misleading or something or
how that would make the movie itself
lose credibility but that might be a
topic for a different dead talk I will
say that it comes at night doesn't have
the punch that it follows had in 14 the
gift had in 15 or split had in 16 but
you can't really blame Schulte for that
it's still very well done
17 might be the year of divisive nough
sacktual ii because i've got mother near
the top of my list as well and who could
forget it I know I included the visit in
2015 but I'm not going to include get
out since that one was much closer to
comedy than it is horror this next one
I'm only gonna
point out because I know people will
pull out some less-than-desirable films
when we get to the 2018 discussion
let's not forget that one of the worst
atrocities of the decade took place in
2017
now at least paranormal activity of the
ghost dimension was the sixth movie of a
franchise that had lost its touch
several movies a cow the bye-bye man
really has no excuses for itself in fact
I saw this movie before it officially
came out this was before it had achieved
its main status and all I could come up
with to say about this film was a movie
so bad I can pretty much guarantee it
will become a meme I literally predicted
the future when I wrote that let's look
at some of the popular reviews the
peepee poo-poo men 457 likes I've been
chanting the byebye man for the last two
hours to see if I can get him to kill me
so I can forget about this movie I'm
sorry I really don't like focusing on
the negative but there's just a special
place in hell for this one so that just
leaves us with 2018 I feel like most of
us will agree that hereditary and a
quiet place should occupy the top two
spots so far this year in some order
insidious the last key wasn't terrible
for a January film and for a fourth film
and a franchise on its third director it
was acceptable the rest of the year
though it literally had people eating
Tide Pods we had the Cloverfield paradox
not the worst thing I've seen and kind
of goes more sci-fi than horror but when
you put it next to the first two movies
it just pales and who could forget this
historic thing as you missed intro role
it
there were a lot of temple movies this
year but did any of them really blow you
away in this case I have to agree with
the author of the article 2018 is a step
down overall from previous years but
before we wrap this up let's revisit my
hypothesis that 2018 is weaker than
recent years but that's partially
because recent years have been pretty
strong
I started this comparison at 2014
because that's when I started logging my
movies however a few Google searches for
horror movies from 2010 to 2013 brought
me back to the dark ages in era where
you were lucky to get an awesome horror
movie once a year let alone 2 or 6 the
tide started to turn no no no not that
time the tide started to turn in late
2014 when people started to chatter
about an incredibly clever monster film
with a creepy synth sound track from
that point we would get a new gem every
year sometimes several 2017 didn't have
a five-star mind-blowing movie leading
the way like the previous years but it
did feature a massive 700 million dollar
grossing picture that floated all the
way to the top of the world of horror
but maybe more impressively it was a hit
with the fans as well so in my opinion
that 2018 is a bit of a dip from recent
years but I'd still consider it to be
part of a pretty awesome stretch of
years in the latter half of this decade
and we've got one more in less than two
months assuming these wildfires don't do
to me what Kerry White did to her prom
classmates I'll make it to the
long-awaited California 2019 and it's
sure to be a year for all you crash
queens and motor babies listen up the
feature is bulletproof that by by man is
secondary
it's time
now and do it loud or boys make some
noise it's Chapter two happy deathday to
you some mutants that are newborn or see
number two
got a new Haley ya gotta wear open my
damn gimme more gimme more gimme more
you don't want to be buried in a pet
cemetery got some j-horror with grudge
no one knows what's up with a child's
coming back and we'll be conjuring are
you afraid of that doc I hope not or you
will not have a good year when Swati 19
is yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
you